that's right insane high school parties
aren't the only movies coming out this
weekend now we got the voice of the
trees to have his shot dr. Seuss is the
Lorax all right so the Lorax is based
off of a dr. Seuss book that I don't
really remember a lot of I remember
green eggs and ham and Cat in the Hat
and a Grinch and all that good stuff so
I don't know if it's just me but the
trailer - the Lorax made it look like
the Zac Efron character and the Taylor
Swift character those are going to be
the main characters in Lorax that and
Danny DeVito who is the Lorax but it's
not really about that all right the Zac
Efron character wants to go find a tree
because Taylor Swift's character wants a
trains the dude who wants to impress a
chick so there you go then he comes
across this crickety really creepy house
in the middle of nowhere where there are
no trees and this guy in there who you
don't really see tells him hey I'm the
reason the trees are all gone so I'm
going to tell you the story of what
happened after that Ed Helms is actually
the main character in this story this
story within the story and now we have
the actual story of what happened to the
trees and the Lorax himself voiced by
Danny DeVito and after that I thought
the Lorax was a really good movie first
of all I liked the fact that it's a
story within a story I've always liked
that movies you know put you in the sea
to finding out what happened to the
trees along with this character and I
thought Danny DeVito as the Lorax was
really funny I thought his dialogue in a
situational humor I thought it was
well-written it was good it's good for
kids as well as adults it's good for
families now I have heard complaints and
reports of people being alike or
actually just a movie conditioning kids
to be tree-huggers and whatnot after
seeing the movie I can be like it's kind
of like Beauty and the Beast it's Beauty
and the Beast about bestiality well yeah
but it has underlying tones it's not
like the movie The Lorax has a message
for kids that is hey go snort some yay
on the playground gravel there are worse
messages to have than the ones in the
Lorax I say ones because there are many
the Lorax does have a message about hey
don't wipe out the trees but that's the
simple message underneath that message I
felt there were a lot of underlying
tones that were more intriguing and
really well-done like what is the price
for success are you willing to sell your
soul for that success and once you do
it's gonna feel fulfilling for you and
for all you people trying to start a
business it has a good message about
don't flood the market with your crap
they did not listen to the Lorax
I thought the movie was a really
well-done movie about this normal person
who has an idea who's driven to be
successful by his family who takes it
too far and how you
that's not a good thing in the end The
Lorax had good animation good character
is a good story some good writing some
good laughs and a few good messages I'm
probably not going to end up buying it
on blu-ray because I don't have kids
however I think it does deserve the
rating I would buy it on blu-ray if I
had kids this parenthesis there just
subtext so what is your favorite dr.
Seuss story be it a book or a movie
whatever it is comment below let me know
and as always if you like what you seen
here and you want to see more click
right here to see more
[Music]